Oscar Serna is speaking in a brand new language.
Oscar is both deaf and blind or deaf-blind.
He works at Gallaudet University on a project tracking the evolution of a language...
...for those who can't see or hear.
This new language is called Pro-Tactile ASL.
The ASL stands for American Sign Language, which uses visual signs for words and phrases.
Pro-Tactile ASL communicates entirely through touch.
For example, here's a sentence in ASL:
Here's how Oscar would say the same sentence in pro-tactile ASL.
Historically, deaf-blind people communicated...
...through American Sign Language, Braille and finger spelling.
...where each letter of each word is signed into a person's hand.
Helen Keller, may be the world's most famous deaf-blind person, used finger spelling.
But those are limiting specially when deaf-blind people want to talk to each other.
Pro-Tactile ASL emerged in the early 2000s, as once isolated deaf-blind people...
...began to form communities.
Deaf-blind people have been adapting American Sign Language...
...and adding gestures for things many languages don't have words for.
For example, this tap on the hand is like nodding.
The language has been evolving since.
Now what's new in pro-tactile is that we're seeing things...
...that were used in  visual sign language be transitioned from the use of space...
...to the use of the perceiver's body.